hi I'm Yanis Pappas listen to my podcast
with me and Chris de Stefano called
history hyenas and I'm here to answer
the Internet and here it is I've been
waiting my whole life for this whoever
wrote this has decent handwriting would
you rather every time you laugh a dog
dies or every time you fall in love
there is a genocide would you rather
every time you laugh a dog dies I am a
dog lover so that's just an easy no on
the dogs dying I want every dog to be
alive but then there'll be too many dogs
and we'll have to kill them anyway so
that's a problem but I'll deal with that
when it comes they'll starve to death or
whatever then we were just wild packs of
dogs everywhere so there will be a
genocide because there'll be wild packs
of dogs everywhere killing people so
hopefully I've fall in love in that time
but I think I just answered two
questions in one and that's the first
time that's ever happened to the
Internet yeah my first question answer
answered the second question so I just
flicked this like I'm on David Letterman
yeah all right all right would you
rather [ __ ] a goat I'm Greek so yes do I
have to even finish that and nobody
knows or you don't give a goat you don't
or you don't [ __ ] a goat but everybody
thinks you did I'm going with [ __ ] a
goat cuz I'm all about new experiences
and I heard they got tight [ __ ] would
you rather always wear a high heels or a
belly shirt okay true story when I was a
kid I used to put on my mom stockings
and high heels and jerk off I don't know
what that means it was an experimental
time in my sexual development and then I
had a stockings fetish for a little
while and I took him off I never used to
put him on but the smell would turn me
on
- and then will my girlfriends wear
stockings everybody liked it and then
now I'm just in the guys so I've gone
through a lot of phases different phases
of my life
who's the one cartoon character who you
would bang
that's easy Papa Smurf next I got daddy
issues when you go to heaven you can
only hang out with people who died the
same way you died how
you trying to go out I will die
hopefully of old age but when I am old
I'm going to do a lot of drugs and I
don't understand why old people don't do
drugs why the older you get the more
conservative you get dude you're 80 this
is your time to do heroin yes like you
know let it go what are you gonna go to
rehab and try to fix your drug addiction
84 no that's why drugs we're on the
ground for old people die in a blaze of
glory I'm gonna get to shootout with the
cops and die with a smile and a peace
sign like this high on cocaine that's
how I'm gonna die would you rather
orgasm every time you hear all-star by
Smash Mouth or hear all start every time
you orgasm I would rather never hear I
can I be deaf at all in this question so
Smash Mouth can be playing while I'm
orgasming but I don't have the my
Faculty of hearing doesn't work because
I don't like Smash Mouth I'm more of a
Miley Cyrus girl would you punch your
grandmother in the face to [ __ ] the girl
your dreams that's tough because one of
these questions is illegal so I'd be
admitting I'm gonna do a crime what I've
but I get caught what I be caught
punching my grandmother if I could punch
my great does my mother have my
grandmother have Alzheimer's because
then I could punch her and she won't
know I can just tell she fell yeah yeah
I bought my grandmother yeah my grandma
was dead but in this hypothetical
scenario that's not real my grandmother
would have Alzheimer's I'd punch her
she'd say why is my face or I say you
fell and then I would bang the girl my
dreams I'm a winner and I'm also smart
criminal okay what STD would you be
willing to have if you were able to pass
it to your biggest enemy
ooh that's definitely gonna be good STD
there's no good as yeah my biggest enemy
has got to be Hillary Clinton so what
kind of STD am I gonna give Hillary I'm
just joking I'm with her but my biggest
enemy that's my biggest enemy is Andrew
Schultz because he's getting too big and
he's becoming a monster and we need to
stop him so I'm gonna give him gonorrhea
and hope that he's he
egos too big and he can't go to the
doctor because it nobody can film in the
doctor's office and make it into content
for the rest of your life would you
rather only have sex in one position or
only be able to watch one porn I'm a
missionary kid so I could I'd rather
just do missionary and I'm married so
it's already done so I'm I need the porn
I need the porn and I mean if I'm
banging my wife
doggystyle and missionary it's still sad
so I need the porn so that's an easy one
whoever wrote this one should be [ __ ]
fired
that is not a challenging question at
all if I was single that would be a
problem all right but you know it's over
this is you know you get married it's
really just a funeral for your penis
would you rather give up appetizers or
desserts for life I'm a buffalo wings
kid a hundred percent I don't have a
sweet tooth
so I'm going I'm going I'm giving up
desserts no more desserts buffalo wings
forever what's one thing a person can
say or do that makes you immediately
hate them they can say patriarchy if I
hear the word patriarchy and then I'll
say oh so you hate the patriarchy where
do you go to school they're gonna go
anyway yeah and I'm gonna go okay who
pays for you to go to NYU and they're
gonna go my dad and I'm gonna say oh so
you study how you're studying how you
figure out how your dad paid for you to
study how your dad paid for you you are
granted the ability to time travel and
visit your past self but you were only
allowed to speak ten words to your past
self to what year would you go and what
would you say I'd go to 1983 eight years
old
Yanis Pappas wearing stockings in high
heels and I would say what are you doing
kid you're a little confused
you got porno mags all over the floor
your dad's about to walk in and ask you
does mother know it's a true story don't
do it yeah that's a true story true
story yeah I just yeah what do you want
me to say yeah she helped me pick the
stockings dad I mean that's the moment
that's why I became a comedian because I
wasn't reared well that's the moment
your dad's supposed to sit you down and
say hey son you're a boy you're a boy
you don't need to put that on those
refer girls you're eight years old
you're a little confused
and you got a little piece and that's my
fault so my dad's got a micro piece
looks like chewing gum in a jew-fro true
story I should be making these up I
should be truthful right because I'm
revealing too much is it necessary to
wash your hands after you take a piss
never I never wash my hands after I take
a piss
in fact the bathroom attendant should
just be called the dude that makes you
wash your [ __ ] hands because if he
wasn't in there nobody's washing their
hands it's like you know if if nobody's
in the bathroom you know that what's
that if snow if a tree falls in the
forest if nobody's there like if
nobody's there it didn't happen no weird
there's no more shame I feel and I don't
know why when I walk out of like a rest
stop bathroom and I didn't wash my hands
and I shouldn't feel that way I'm never
gonna see these people again
I don't care about them getting in a car
but I also feel like a dirty that I
don't wash my hands but when I'm alone
I'm like I did the right I made the
right move all right you're building
your dick from scratch this is a this is
good okay that's it this is a real dream
of mine and you can make it as big as
you want but for every inch you add you
lose two years of your life how big do
you make it I just need seven man I just
want to get to seven yeah cuz I'm just
sliding into six in fact I don't even
need the inches if I could just get my
foreskin back that will give me another
inch if you ever think about guys who
are uncircumcised have a little bit of
an unhappy little extra inch that's not
yeah I'll give up the size for the
aesthetic though really yeah
I'll take the hood I'll take to hide
I'll clean it no I'll take good I'll
deal with my dicks political beliefs you
know once in a while Kim wants to grab a
tiki torch that's his business as long
as I get that extra inch would you
rather have sex with a blind person or a
deaf person I'm going to go with a blind
person I mean because my body looks like
yogurt with hair in it so
rather j-just felt it and didn't see it
I'd feel more secure would you rather be
able to drink with no hangover pick up
anyone you want from the bar or be best
friends with Joe Pesci would you rather
drink with no hangover pick up anyone
you want like to pick up anyone I wanted
a bar why wouldn't want to hang out with
Joe Pesci guys like 90 he's probably
he's not the Joe Pesci from the movies
he's some dumb actor actor suck so no
Joe Pesci and hangover yeah I could be
able to hangover I want to pick up
chicks at the bar but again I'm married
so Joe Pesci from casino I'm hanging out
with Joe Pesci from casino yeah that'd
just be fun cuz I would just start
fights just that and set him off like
for no reason I'd be like yo is that my
water on tip me big man it's my water
I'm doing Joe Pesci think I'd just get
my water yeah it's [ __ ] what are you
[ __ ] you know yeah I would [ __ ]
hang with Joe Pesci thanks
you